science breakthroughs daily from science
mission in a study published in cell
reports researchers found that when the
harmonica gone like peptide-1 that his
glp-1 was reduced in the central nervous
system of lab mice they were 8 and
consumed more high-fat food conversely
when they enhanced glp-1 signaling in
the brain of mice they were able to
block the preference of high-fat foods
authors found that activating the glp-1
hormone in the mesolimbic system in
their communication between neurons
which communicate to control reward
behaviors including eating thus
increasing glp-1 could be used to change
eating preference next step 3 has been
implicated in prostate cancer in men but
targeting of the interleukin 6 tie 3
axis in patients has failed to provide
therapeutic benefit researchers show
that genetic inactivation of stat3 or
il-6 signaling in a feat and efficient
prostate cancer mouse model accelerate
cancer progression leading to metastasis
loss of stat3 signaling disrupts the RF
mdm2 p53 tumor suppressor axis bypassing
senescence leading to metastasis thus
authors shall in the current notion of
treating the prostate cancer patients
with stat3 blockers for more news
visitors at www science mission calm or
science mission facebook page thanks for
watching